même si la plupart de nos transactions
se font par carte ou sans contact
saviez vous qu'on pouvait toujours payer
ses achats avec de vieux billets en
papier
même ceux qui ne sont plus imprimer
depuis des années mais la banque du
canada retire le cours légal de
certaines devises papier en 2021 les
billets de 1 2 2
ceux de 25 car ça existe 2 500 et 2000 $
ne pourront plus être utilisés
légalement pour faire une transaction
mais les banques pourront toujours
voulait rembourser
on les des monnaies de 6 po sont
toujours au bon ils vont chicoine de
monnaie de versailles rappelle que
certaines coupures peuvent valoir leur
pesant d'or à la vente la valeur
nominale
mais on peut avoir beaucoup plus que son
nez des clientèles des collèges alors le
biais de 500 $ de 1935 imprimé en
français par exemple
il n'en resterait qu'un ou deux
exemplaires au canada - sans art ex
français de même ap je paye 50 à 100
milles dans leur peau sol il ya aussi de
25 $ qui célèbre le 25e anniversaire du
couronnement de george cinq points c'est
un biais qui se transige pas loin quand
même de 7000 $
c'est quand même un bon miel pour ce qui
est des billets de un ou deux dollars la
banque du canada
on a tellement imprimés qui n'ont pas
vraiment de valeur et c'est ce que cela
même dans 50 ans à votre avis comment on
connaît nos sous noirs qui ont arrêté en
on en a encore aujourd'hui pour sa
valeur c'est bien alors on pas tu devras
l'art
bref si vous trouvez une pile de vieux 2
n'espérez pas faire fortune ici vincent
maison de radio canada montréal